[Música]
hablamos de economía en directo américa
de france 24 luis mendez zúrich y ya con
nosotros en el estudio de louis sé cómo
durmió descansó como amaneció y
miércoles
bueno muy activo para hablar de reino
unido porque se dieron a conocer los
datos de inflación en ese país como esta
no son nada alentadores raúl porque
éstos mostraron un alza al nivel
interanual hasta ubicarse en 9 por
ciento durante el mes de abril este es
el dato más alto en 40 años para esa
nación una cifra emitida por la oficina
nacional de estadística fue superior a
la mostrada por el país durante la
recesión que vivió en la década de 1990
el incremento fue de dos puntos
porcentuales
respecto a marzo pasado cuando la tasa
interanual se situó en
7% la guerra en ucrania que entre otras
cosas ha impulsado un alza en los
precios de la energía que alcanzaron
hasta un 54 por ciento se erige como el
principal factor en el incremento de
este indicador además del aumento en el
precio de los productos de uso diario
bienes y servicios durante toda esta
situación le pregunto qué medidas está
tomando el gobierno para entonces
controlar los precios hay que ser claros
por el momento el gobierno no se ha
pronunciado sobre acciones a tomar para
frenar la inflación pese a que ésta se
ubica muy por encima de las previsiones
de acuerdo con el diario the guardian
los datos de inflación aunado a la
escasez de trabajadores calificados han
provocado un aumento en el temor de una
posible recesión por ello algunos
sectores ya están presionando al
canciller de hacienda para que ofrezca
apoyo a hogares y empresas lo que sí se
ha venido haciendo desde el pasado mes
de diciembre y por parte del banco de
inglaterra ese en este caso el
incremento en la tasa de interés de
referencia hasta alcanzar los niveles
más altos en los últimos 13 años
seguimos en europa louis para hablar de
la preocupación por el suministro de
gases procedentes de rusia este ha sido
un amplio tema de debate entre los
integrantes del bloque de los 27 durante
las últimas semanas para disminuir la
dependencia de gas y petróleo ruso esto
como parte de las sanciones
a ese país por la invasión a ucrania sin
embargo lograr el consenso deseado ha
sido complicado por la dependencia de
dispares que han mostrado a los países
de la unión europea por ejemplo allí hay
países como alemania que importa entre
un 50 y un 55 por ciento del gas que
consume de rusia pero también está a
hungría o eslovaquia cuyo porcentaje de
importación ronda el 90 por ciento del
gas o cuentan con una infraestructura
destinada a la refinación solamente para
el petróleo ruso como es el caso de
eslovaquia pero el bloque está decidido
a disminuir la dependencia de gas y
petróleo ruso en los próximos años y por
ello ha anunciado este 18 de mayo que
planea movilizar hasta 300.000 millones
de euros en inversiones para 2030 con el
fin de acabar con esta importación de
gas y petróleo ruso el plan entre otras
cosas prevé el ahorro de energía limpia
y la eliminación gradual del uso de
combustibles fósiles louis y en
argentina- la canasta básica alimentaria
registró un aumento durante el mes de
abril así es este aumento habría ubicado
la canasta básica alimentaria en 7 % de
acuerdo con los datos emitidos por el
instituto nacional de estadísticas y
censos que analizó el incremento mensual
del indicador que incluye solamente los
productos comestibles por lo que un
hogar requerido de al menos 42 mil 527
pesos argentinos es decir unos 360
dólares para poder comer por otro lado
la canasta básica total tuvo un alza
mensual de 62 por ciento y se ubicó en
95 mil 260 con 37 pesos argentinos esto
es poco más de 806 dólares si comparamos
estos datos con el salario actual en
argentina que recordemos que fue
incrementado en 38 mil 900 a 38 mil 940
pesos durante el pasado mes de abril a
unos
350 punto 9 dólares y en junio pasará a
45 puntos 45 mil 540 pesos argentinos
son unos 385 dólares estaríamos hablando
de casi el doble para tener la canasta
básica total
cubierta así es le trae recuerdos no sé
si usted hablemos de indicadores
económicos pero los indicadores
económicos sobre todo en asia han
cerrado con números mixtos cabe destacar
el particular avance que tuvo sobre el
final de la jornada en mercados de hong
kong el hang seng para cerrar con
números positivos en europa hay números
negativos
básicamente por los datos de inflación
en el reino unido y también la
preocupación que existe en torno a la
energía procedente de rusia cifra el día
louis tiene que ver en este caso con los
7 mil 900 millones de dólares que fue el
gasto militar de méxico en el año 2021
el más alto en los últimos siete años
que se ha incrementado un 31 por ciento
entre 2015 y 2022 louis como siempre
gracias por toda la información
económica y nos vamos directo hasta
caracas ahí ya está lista daniela
zambrano para hablar de nuestro país que
pasa ya vamos a verlo